hey thank you for joining us at the
microsoft research summit 2021 i'm
jonathan bisk from carnegie mellon
university and today i'm going to be
talking about a new data set that we've
just released as part of a nurip's
challenge web qa multi-hop and
multi-modal question answering this is
joint work with a number of
collaborators around microsoft research
and the
lead author on this is my student ying
cheng who i'll reference again later in
the presentation
so what are we doing here and what's
sort of the point of this this kind of
data set and introducing a new challenge
so the idea here is that the way that we
access the web when we're using it is
that we'll type questions into these
little boxes and we assume that
some magical engine is going to be able
to find the answer but that answer may
not rely in text it may rely on images
or some other modality so we're trying
to take one step towards moving models
towards the kinds of web experiences
that humans have so let me make that
more concrete
i have a question like are there picnic
tables in chenle park that's a local
park here in pittsburgh so if i go to
bing and i search that i'm going to get
a couple of answers so i might get this
first one here saying that there's a
some sort of blanket and board in
pittsburgh is going to have some sort of
a picnic maybe in schenley park doesn't
answer my question i might get this
other thing about the parks department
website which is talking a little bit
about some of the facilities uh the fact
that you can have picnics there still
not answering my question so i've got
these snippets which are you know
semantically related they're relevant
except that they're not actually what
i'm looking for and as a human we sort
of already would have guessed that when
i told you i was going to ask the
question are there picnic tables
you probably don't even look at these
sets of search results you don't even
look at that main page of text because
you know that there's this other tab
that will just give you the answer
immediately so here we see it the first
thing is someone's picture of a picnic
bench in shenley park
we also see some
maybe picnic tables which are not
helpful so it's not the case that every
image is going to answer our question
but it is the case that some answers are
just more readily accessible if we have
access to a second modality if we have
access to in this case images and so
then what we want is that we eventually
have some sort of a search engine we
have bing or whatever it may be that
basically takes in that question
aggregates the knowledge that's
available to it across both of these
modalities and then produces a fluent
answer so yes there are uncovered picnic
benches in schenley park now there may
also be covered picnic benches but we
don't have evidence for that here and so
this is the kind of reasoning that we
would want it to have it's sort of
correct it's multimodal and it
potentially uses multiple sources and
and cites it and cites them as part of
that
now i also mentioned multi-hop in the
title
because there's also more complicated
questions that we tend to see
or we might want to be able to ask a
system so for example what type of
currency was used during cleopatra the
eighth's reign it's a somewhat specific
question you can imagine these are the
kinds of questions that children that
are trying to cheat on their homework
will tend to put into a search engine
and so what we need is
we do get relevant information from bing
so here we get something about
telematic
coinage which is actually going to be
the answer but there's nothing here that
specifies cleopatra we then get this
other source that tells us about
previous rulers and then a reference to
this last queen cleopatra and that she
was during this age that dynasty
overlapped and so what we need are both
of those pieces of information to be
aggregated so that we can actually
produce an answer in this case just the
simple phrase um solemn ptolemaic
coinage
and so the idea here is that the kinds
of things that you and i do when we walk
up to a search engine are take a bunch
of snippets take a bunch of images we
have some preconceived notion of where
the answer probably is going to be and
then some way that we might reconcile
pieces of information in order to get
the correct full answer and we just want
systems to be able to do that as well
right now the literature is largely
split so we have people that are
focusing on these kinds of multi-hop
questions in the text domain we have
people that are working on increasingly
strong visual uh challenges but we're
not seeing something that's at that
intersection that's doing the same thing
that we're doing aggregating across both
so
what's the difference between questions
that are being addressed to for instance
images versus to text
well if we look at kind of a word cloud
this is from the data set that we've
collected you start to see things about
libraries artwork churches cathedrals
attractions these are places you know
people places things stuff that you see
when you're out and about in the world
very different from
clinical psychology natural history
these um slightly more maybe academic
topics that are sometimes present in the
text corpora and so again in the same
way that we know that if i'm looking to
see if there's a picnic bench an image
is going to quickly answer the question
we want our systems to be able to do
that to be able to reason across both of
these types of knowledge
so
how do i know
that
let's say
people are interested in these kinds of
questions well i know that they are
because i ask these kinds of questions i
do this kind of reasoning and everyone
i've spoken to has fired off at least
one query in the last week or month
where they didn't think it was going to
be that complicated the system didn't
answer it correctly and they had to do a
little bit of digging the answers were
there but they had to find them for
themselves
so we do know that people are answering
the asking these questions of web search
but they're not doing it at scale
so and the correct answer in some sense
to do people ask these questions of web
search is no because while they're there
they're very rare we've all been trained
out of it we've all been trained that
this question is probably a little bit
too hard and so i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna expect anything of it and instead
we put keywords in and then try to do
multiple searches to aggregate the
information
and the way that we know this as i was
saying is this is rare
is that we actually went and looked at
the bing logs so without going into too
much more detail here
we know both from those logs that people
are asking these questions and we also
know that it's pretty rare that they're
actually either getting an answer or in
general that they you know follow up
with these kinds of things because they
they get sort of disheartened by the
fact that there really just isn't the
kind of response that they wanted when
they thought it was probably something
simple
so we have to address this problem we
can't just go and grab a bunch of logs
and then you know answer those questions
we instead have to collect these
questions artificially we have to
construct a scenario so that we can
train systems so that in the future we
don't have this problem in the future we
can deploy systems that are able to do
this kind of complicated reasoning this
cross-modal reasoning these kind of full
sentence kinds of answers that you would
want from an assistant
and that way when people come to a
search engine they actually ask more of
these things we get a nice sort of
feedback loop because they're getting
some of what they want and so then they
give us more data to increasingly sort
of build robust systems
so how did we collect the data so what
we did was we had a bunch of users on
mechanical turk
and this is for an image example here
that we showed them topically related
images so these may be based off of the
same location or the same sort of type
of structures or things like this
users actually also annotators actually
also proposed possible clusters that
would be useful for us and then we asked
them grab one or two of these images and
ask a question that would sort of
require information aggregation across
them
so here you're seeing a simple interface
they choose one two three four five or
six they write some sort of a question
and they provide us an answer now we
want to make sure that what they're
providing us is correct so we have a
pretty rigorous validation process which
i'm not going to go into in too much
detail here but basically there's a sort
of a correctness and an agreement aspect
to it so we have people go through and
say like are these
images that are being used are the facts
that the person is relying on actually
valid are these accurate are these you
know do they correctly merge to answer
the question and then we also run
another validation
where we have people given the question
and those same sources produce their own
answer so we can see whether or not
they're producing very similar sorts of
answers so we can get to a place where
we have data that looks very much like
what a human would want so how much data
are we talking about so i'm going to
break it up first by modality so in
terms of questions that rely on images
we're looking at an overall here just
shy of around 20 000 examples same in
the text you see these are split up
predominantly in train and then we have
a smaller dev and a larger test set so
overall about 34 000 of these
pairs for training
sets the sources the question the answer
and then 5000 for development and seven
and a half thousand or so for testing
the other thing is we want to make sure
that there's no sort of obvious
sort of artifacts in the data that
people are going to be able to have
their models pick up on and so what
we're doing here is in the same way that
when you show up to a website there's
maybe the two facts that you need and
eight facts that are irrelevant we also
are going to parallel that with
distractors in both modalities so you
have an image the questions tend to be
about 23 words on average the answers
maybe take about 21 words on average
and then you have two sources of
additional text so every image comes
with captions and all text is a snippet
and so we're getting we're going to have
sort of correct captions that are almost
exactly the same length distributions as
incorrect captions um then similarly for
the text side we have this kind of thing
with snippets being uh distractors that
are sort of parallel in length and you
see the questions are similar in length
between the two modalities the answers
are slightly different so overall
we're not seeing anything where there's
a clear giveaway that like oh there's a
few more words here it's probably the
correct answer that tends not to be the
case and so we don't have those kinds of
spurious issues in the data
the other problem that we had to address
in this work is how do you evaluate so
so far we've just been saying like okay
very intuitive paradigm this is
something you and i do all the time uh
we're going to have our systems do
something very similar they're going to
go through the facts they're going to
give us an answer but that answer is
natural language text
and if you have a system which is
producing
a full sentence
there's a whole different research
agenda there on just how to do
evaluation of nlg systems
so the way that we try to address this
without sort of taking on that full
challenge is breaking up the evaluation
into two pieces we have what is sort of
a fluency score with a little bit of
semantics mixed in we're relying on bart
score for this and then we have an
accuracy where we actually had
annotators provide sort of what is the
noun phrase what is the key entity that
answers this question or maybe just the
the key property so you know a color and
so we can check for those
we can also make sure that they're still
producing fluent and coherent language
and then we can simply multiply those
two scores together
in order to give a sort of overall sense
of how well a system is performing
so that's what the numbers are that
you're about to see on the next slide
so we have how well can a model retrieve
the right sources versus a human humans
are much better at it
how well can a system perform if it has
predicted sources and how well can a
system or a human perform with sort of
the ground truth sources and the only
thing i want to draw your attention to
here very quickly is that while fluency
really you know pretty impressive um
accuracy really substantially uh
different and so there's definitely more
that can be done in terms of language
generation make it sort of more natural
sounding but this is really the focus of
this challenge and that's also why you
end up with this really big overall gap
between humans and systems
so i wanted to kind of give you a few
other little quick teasers
before we close so this this gives you
kind of a layout there's an interactive
version of this you can play around with
of the types of questions that people
are asking
but the important takeaway is that you
have these kinds of questions broken up
into a bunch of different semantic
categories do they do the systems answer
yes no questions well can they choose
between contrasting options well
can they handle color
questions things like this and you see
that certain tasks are much harder than
others
none of them are in general all that
hard for humans so in particular
i think this is not going to come as a
surprise to anybody but shape and number
can you reason about counts can you
reason about inequalities this is
something that the systems that we
currently have are just completely
incapable of doing they're looking to
basically copy an answer from the text
they're not looking to reason but you
have to do a certain amount of reasoning
if you're going to do multi-hop you have
to be able to aggregate information and
knowledge and produce something new
the final column here text base so these
are the ones where we don't have sort of
a clear
sort of
maybe sort of finite set of answers so
yes and no being a finite set of just
two and so these are places where we're
talking about sort of open domain
entities and we see that there's still a
very substantial gap here so in terms of
knowing which entities in a snippet are
related to the question maybe the
systems do an okay job how those
entities relate to each other relate to
properties of one another still have
quite a bit of ways to go
so
where does that leave us well it leaves
us with a pretty long road ahead so this
is just one quick failure case that i
thought was pretty funny
we have what is the sculpted bust at the
baroque library prague wearing on its
head and then we provide the image so
step one figuring out that this is the
bust that we're talking about the
systems are given access to some
metadata that really shouldn't be a huge
problem for them it's something that
even without metadata humans don't
really have a trouble figuring out if
you have a contrasting set of things
that are not busts
um but what we see is that the model has
said very fluently the sculpted busk
bust at the baroque library prague is
wearing a helmet on its head and why
helmet because that's a natural
continuation it's a totally fluent thing
the correct answer is obviously a flower
wreath so
visual understanding
still still still going to take a while
anyway if you want to learn more about
this the paper can participate in the
challenge the website is here there's a
leaderboard for you to participate and
again
huge shout out to my student
chang who's actually the lead on all of
this collection thank you